foreign
[Music]
exciting was taking the original Meg and
then supercharging it and giving it
bigger creatures but we've got company
bigger monsters that's the biggest snake
I've ever seen
biggest Meg anyone's ever seen
anybody got action everybody make it to
the station you can make it keep going
Jason Statham is perfect for this one
look at this Statham's a great Action
Hero he's just a quintessential badass
three massive Megs and who knows what
else have escaped the breach there's a
team of them now at any turn a Megalodon
could jump out at you we've never seen
this before they hunted it back
wow
not only is the Meg the antagonist
there's a Maelstrom of enemies it's like
Jurassic Park underwater yeah bring it
on let's get more creatures from the
deep
this is a bad idea just a little bit
I think it's gonna be even more jump
scary
what is sheer aquatic chaos and it's
awesome this is going to be megalodonish
this feels unpleasantly familiar what
happened last time you don't want to
know
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone can relax this place magproof
connect to the trench in cinemas August
4.
[Music]